Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Pritla und heute ist Mittwoch und das heißt, heute gibt's kein Corona-Wikli
sondern,
langersehnt dann äh auch schon vor einiger Zeit angekündigt, dass äh Update zum Brexit mit äh John, mit John Wors. Hallo.
Ja, John, ist äh wieder einiges passiert und ich glaube, ein ganz guter Zeitpunkt jetzt mal wieder zurückzuschauen, sind ein paar wesentliche Dinge passiert, wie die Wahl in
Schottland, aber natürlich ist es insgesamt auch äh vorangegangen. Es läuft alles so ein bisschen unter dem Radar der deutschen Öffentlichkeit, möchte ich meinen, man nimmt es
eigentlich aus Deutschland heraus dann doch eher so am Rande war alles.
Genau, das stimmt. Ähm also es, es herrscht bestimmt auch eine eine gewisse Brexit-Müdigkeit, äh,
in Großbritannien und auch natürlich dann in Paris, Berlin und und in Brüssel
Brexit ist irgendwie, so zumindest die vertragischen Aspekte größtenteils so gelöst, aber die praktischen Probleme gehen nicht weg und manche von den praktischen Problemen werden.
Immer schwieriger zu lösen. Also das werden wir dann diskutieren. Also eine gewisse Müdigkeit kann ich durchaus verstehen. Ähm aber mittelfristig ähm.
Wir brauchen eine neue Beziehung zwischen Großbritannien und andere Länder der EU. Ähm also das das wird uns äh viel Zeit kosten in den kommenden Monaten und Jahren. Brexit äh ist nie beendet irgendwie.
Nee, Breaks ist bestimmt nicht äh beendet und ich glaube, es sind auch äh viele so ein bisschen jetzt in halb acht Stellung, was natürlich auch den Ausgang der Wahlen in Deutschland betrifft, weil das natürlich für den zukünftigen Kurs Europas sicherlich auch äh bedeutend sein wird.
Ja, schauen wir doch mal äh kurz zurück. Also wir hatten die letzte Sendung Ende Januar, veröffentlicht. Das heißt, da sind jetzt äh
gut vier Monate her, damals hatte sich äh das, was ja das in Krafttreten aller Verträge
ähm was das sozusagen bewirken würde gerade erst so abgezeichnet
insbesondere der Warenverkehr, der ja so ein bisschen im Fokus stand, war etwas schwierig zu,
teilen, gerade weil der Januar traditionell und natürlich, weil die Firmen auch wussten, dass eine Umstellung ansteht, so ein bisschen ähm weniger äh aktiv,
ohnehin mit sich bringt und man erwartete dann, normalerweise hätte man halt erwartet, dass es spätestens im Februar dann wieder anzieht.
Ja, genau, aber grob zusammengefasst, äh es gab.
November und Dezember so eine gewisse Stalk-Pilling, also ähm das
viele britischen Industrien haben möglichst viele Waren importiert vor,
Treten von den neuen Abkommenden. Also das war ein Grund für den sehr ruhigen Handelsmonat Januar und im zweiten Grund war Großbritannien und die EU war mitten in die schwerste Phase der Corona-Pandemie,
im Dezember und im Januar. Also diese beiden Sachen haben den Verkehr in in Januar zum Teil.
Begrenzt, was wir dann gesehen haben, waren die äh Handel war deutlich geringer im Januar, so waren dreißig oder bis fünfunddreißig Prozent runter. Das kam ein bisschen zurück
im, im Februar, also rebondiert, äh aber aber hat nie Stimmen
vor Brexitebene erreicht. Wenn wir schauen zum Beispiel in den, in den Handelssaalen, Exporte aus Deutschland zu diversen Ländern der Welt. Deutschen zeigte,
so ich sehe gute Ergebnissen in den letzten paar Monaten, mehr Exporte nach China, nach anderen europäischen Ländern.
Aber äh immer noch ein äh ein ein Minus von Minus dreizehn Prozent äh Exporte nach Großbritannien. Und es könnte noch schlimmer sein, weil,
Wir sind noch in in sogenannte ähm äh Periode mit mit ähm managen. Das bedeutet, dass alle waren,
von EU-Länder nach Großbritannien durch den Hafen von Dova werden bei der
Einreise in Großbritannien nicht kontrolliert. Nur die Waren, die von Großbritannien nach der EU gehen, werden dann in, in, in, in Ostende oder Rottedame oder, oder, oder, oder, oder Kelly oder oder, oder sonstiger Hafen
Das bedeutet, die Kontrollen sind nur in eine Richtung zur Zeit. Also hinter diesen Statistiken und die britische Regierung hat diese Statistiken so, so, so sehr ähm
so so formuliert, dass es gibt ganz viele, fast so viele LKWs, die durchfahren, als vor dem Austritt.
Aber die die Leute, die für Lieferketten zuständig sind, sind es gibt einen großen Teil der LKWs, die liefern Sachen nach Großbritannien, aber fahren dann leer nach die EU zurück
also erst nach dieser Einführung von die kompletten Kontrollen auf der Seite vorgesehen für den ersten Juli,
ähm dann werden wir da mal sehen, wie sieht es dann aus äh definitiv.
So oder so zeichnet sich dann, glaube ich, aber auch schon einen Personalmangel auch ab, weil einfach viele Leute gar keine Lust haben, nach Großbritannien zu äh fahren, weil eigentlich das wie eine Spedition arbeitet, ist,
Hinweg die eine Ladung auf dem Rückweg, die andere Ladung, dass man auf beiden in beiden Richtungen Geld verdienen kann. Jetzt verdient man quasi nur in eine Richtung.
Dann natürlich die Kosten für für britische Unternehmer und das auch anderen Häfen wie Saddam oder oder Felix. Also das hat ein ein bedeuten
Einfluss auf die auf Handel überall in Großbritannien. Es ist nicht nur auf der äh fokussiert.
Genau, du hast gesagt, dreizehn Prozent Rückgang der Importe aus der EU äh nach Großbritannien äh in die andere Richtung sieht's halt ganz anders aus. Ich glaube, das liegt so bei fünfunddreißig Prozent Rückgang, ne, oder dreiunddreißig weiß ich immer ganz genau.
Und und es es ist von diversen Sektoren sehr stark abhängig. Besonders Lebensmittel
Fisch, Fleisch aus Großbritannien.
Da gibt's eine enorme Reihe an Problemen, also eine Reduzierung von über neunzig Prozent von von Milchprodukte von Großbritannien nach EU-Länder. Ähm also es ist nicht das,
generell alles Sektoren äh gleich betroffen sind, also manche Sektoren deutlich haben dort deutlich größere Schwierigkeiten als aus anderen.
Aber es ist vor allem die Landwirtschaft, die halt hart betroffen ist. Fisch, du hast gesagt, äh Milch, äh Fleisch und und das hat,
mehrere Gründe. Ich bin mir grad jetzt nicht ganz so sicher, inwieweit wir das letzte Mal schon angesprochen haben, aber es sind ja so Geschichten, wie das bestimmte Klassifikationen wegfallen, ne, also
Fischereien, die vorher einfach in die EU liefern konnten und dann wurde dort eine Nachbehandlung durchgeführt, die jetzt nicht mehr möglich ist, die quasi im Land gemacht werden müsste, wofür es aber gar nicht die Kapazitäten äh äh,
teilweise.
Also es es gab ein großes Streit zum zum Thema ähm äh Meeresfrüchte ähm aber nicht
so direkt aus dem Meer, sondern von äh wir sammeln so Fish Farming.
Ähm also das es wäre möglich für für diese Produktion nach Schottland zum Beispiel direkt nach EU-Länder äh exportiert zu werden äh und da bei der
bei der Bearbeitung in Frankreich oder in Belgien da bearbeitet zu werden. Aber es gibt,
keinen juristischen Rahmen, um sowas zu machen, mit ein nicht,
EU-Land. Und es gab dann einen Streit zwischen der der Umweltminister in Großbritannien und und vieler Fischer, die haben gesagt, Moment mal, also sie haben uns genau den Gegenteil gesagt vor dem Austritt und jetzt ist unser kompletten Business,
vollkommen zerstört, wegen dem wegen dem Austritt
und weil es auch wichtig ist, ist viele von diesen von diesen Industrien ähm auch im Bereich der der Agrarindustrie sind in unter dem Ärmsten
periphäre
Teilen von Großbritannien. Es ist nicht die Großstädten, die betroffen sind, sondern ländliches Raum, Schottland, westlichen Teilen von Vailes, wo dem Soputo Inlands pro Kopf nicht enorm hoch ist. Also das ist dann ein politisches Problem, in besonders in diese Regionen.
Mhm.
Ja und das bedeutet ja auch, dass also äh selbst wenn geliefert werden kann, kann halt nur Tage später geliefert werden, was bei Frischwar natürlich ein absoluter Mahlus ist, das heißt, selbst wenn man eine Lieferung durchbekommt, die dann schon teurer war, weil der Aufwand größer war
weil mehr Zeit auch eigentlich mehr, mehr Geld bedeutet, Personal et cetera. Äh und dann erzielt man auch noch niedrigere Preise.
Also das ist ja alles äh hängt ja alles miteinander zusammen und ich glaube, diese ganze kausal Kette, die wird jetzt erst langsam allen so richtig klar.
Genau und und wir haben bis jetzt keinen Punkt erreicht, wo alle Beteiligten wissen, wie sie.
Alles dann mittelfristig aus
Was ist überhaupt die Zukunft für eine Fischereifirma im im Westen Schottlands oder ein Lärmproduzentin im in Not, weil also wir haben keine es es gibt keine äh
kann konkrete Idee, von wie, wie könnte sowas dann aussehen mittelfristig?
Mhm. Ja, also.
Im Bereich Handel, äh läuft's auf jeden Fall nicht gut und das wird natürlich dann auch auf die britische Wirtschaft die entsprechende Auswirkungen haben und sich zwangsläufig in den Zahlen niederschlagen.
Ähnlich sieht es ja im Dienstleistungssektor aus, der ja im Prinzip auch überhaupt gar keine Anschlussregelung hat. Also gerade die Finanzindustrie, die ja einen Großteil der Einnahmen Großbritanniens ausgemacht hat, verliert den Markt eigentlich vollständig und es,
glaube ich, so eine theoretische.
Über eine Neuverhandlung Mitte des Jahres. Aber ich habe so den Eindruck, es macht sich niemand eigentlich wirklich Hoffnung, dass da Fieber rauskommt, weil welches Interesse sollte die EU haben?
Genau und und das war dann weiterhin verzögert. Ähm.
Der Mindestlohn, der dafür verantwortlich ist, ähm äh der ähm.
Der Finanzminister in Großbritannien der seien Hauptpriorität ist, ist
Boris Johnsons Nachfolger zu sein. Also er kümmert sich nicht um die die praktischen Auswirkungen des Brexit, weil das parteipolitisch für ihn so schlecht ist bei den Konservativen
Ähm auch für anderen Sektoren besonders äh so Kulturindustrien, Musikindustrie, in Großbritannien sind auch.
Richtig heftig betroffen, besonders wenig, es geht um Wiesen,
für Musiker, die ja auf so auf Tour sind in anderen europäischen Ländern gehen wollen. Da gibt's eine Menge Kampagnen, besonders Elton John, hat sich äh dafür eingesetzt, also für für junge britische Musiker, die dann,
Konzerte in anderen europäischen Ländern machen wollen. Äh da gab's auch überhaupt keine Fortschritte. Ähm.
Auch diese praktischen Auswirkungen. Da gab's eine sehr wichtige, praktische Änderung,
und nicht dem in die in so eine gute, pragmatische Richtung ist es, es war aus meiner Sicht sehr gefährlich.
Boris Johnson hat der Zuständigkeit innerhalb der Regierung für Brexit zum Nachverhandlungen,
umgebaut im März. Er hat Michael mit David Forst ähm ähm ersetzt.
Und Froster ist mehr als Golf, so ein Hardliner. So ein Souverän und er hat wenig Bock,
diese Reihe von so praktischen Problemen überhaupt zu beheben. Ähm also die die diese Problemen sind für ihn.
Keinerlei wichtig. Ähm also das bedeutet, dass die Chancen diese Arten von von Problemen zu beheben, sind meiner Meinung nach,
geringer jetzt aus die vor ein paar Monaten waren.
Mhm. Jetzt äh ist natürlich auch die Frage, wie verhält sich eigentlich die EU äh zu
Auswirkungen,
ja nochmal eine Zustimmung des EU Parlaments. Das stand ja noch aus, weil ja die so kurzfristig Ende Dezember dann erst final ausgehandelten Regelungen dann zwar mehr oder weniger in Kraft traten, aber
eigentlich ja noch nicht offiziell vollständig juristisch abgesegnet waren in der EU.
Ja genau, also das das hieß ähm, ähm also vorläufige Applikation.
Anwendung, ja, vorläufige Anwendung.
Anwendung. Ähm und Grund dafür, weil das Europäische Parlament hat sich gesagt, okay sorry, wir haben nicht genug Zeit, um alles,
genau so beobachten oder so analysieren, weil dem vorläufigen Vertrag,
kam aus der Verhandlung am am vierundzwanzigsten Dezember.
Manfred Weber im Europäischen Parlament hat so gesagt, nee, sorry, dass das machen wir nicht, wir brauchen mehr Zeit. Unsere Ratifikation ähm findet dann erst im im Frühling statt. Ähm.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin von dieser äh ganze Prozedere im europäischen Parlament tief enttäuscht. Ähm.
Weil es herrschte schon in in mancher Themenbereiche, Handel, Dienstleistungen,
anderen Schwierigkeiten, besonders sind nur die Elan, die werden wir später diskutieren. Und das Europäische Parlament hat im Dezember gesagt, okay, wir nehmen ausreichend Zeit, alles genauer, so zu beobachten.
Aber doch dann am Ende, Ende April hat das Europäische Parlament alles einfach so zugestimmt. Ähm ohne großes Kritik an was die Briten,
gerade machen. Und ich sehe auf der EU Seite vielleicht wegen so einer einer bestimmten Brexit-Müdigkeit in Großbritannien,
Keine klare Linie der EU. Ähm.
Äh vier Jahre lang Chefunterverhandeler für die EU. Der der hat
die diese Rolle nicht mehr nach Frankreich gegangen und will in ähm französische Präsidentschaft war als zwanzig bis zweiundzwanzig kandidieren. Kann ich durchaus verstehen
habe sein Nachfolger des stellvertretende Präsident der Europäischen Kommission, der es nicht so,
klug als Verhandler in Vergleich zu seinem Vorgänger. Auch im Europäischen Parlament gab's keine klare Linie. Ähm und auch in Sachen ähm so
Covid und ähm Beschaffung von ähm äh von von äh Lieferketten.
Von
da gab's auch Schwierigkeiten zwischen Großbritannien und und die EU. Also das bedeutet aus meiner Sicht, es fehlt auf die EU-Seite ein bisschen so eine kohärente Linie in Richtung Großbritannien zur Zeit. Ähm also das ist
das sind wirklich ein großes Problem. Ähm und niemanden kümmert sich äh darum,
in Brüssel, weil wie du kannst du deine Einführung gesagt hast? Äh es, es herrscht gerade so eine eine gewisse Brexit-Müdigkeit in.
Aber trotzdem ist jetzt erstmal alles ratifiziert und ähm letztlich gibt es für für UK so richtig keinen Hebel, um eigentlich irgendwelche Verbesserungen einzuklagen jetzt, oder?
Siehst du da irgendwas, wo die EU jetzt ein Problem hätte? Also was, was für Druckmittel könnte denn.
Also grundsätzlich, es gibt zwei zwei Arten von Problemen, die nicht komplett.
Voneinander zu trennen sind. Also das sind die Problemen an oder bei bei der ähm so Handelsverkehr.
Nach Großbritannien aus anderen Ländern der EU.
Und dann Handelsprobleme, die Not spezifisch für Nordirland sind. Also die sind die beiden.
Die beiden Arten von Problemen. Und in beiden Fällen ist das Lebensmittelindustrie besonders hart betroffen
Und da gibt's schon eine Diskussion in Großbritannien. Gips so einer Verbesserungsbedarf im Bereich der Lebensmittelsicherheit.
Oder könnte man irgendwas dann da so verbessern? Es es.
Grade eine Debatte. Brauche Großbritannien und die EU.
Eine Lebensmittelsicherheitsvertrag wie den jetzigen Vertrag zwischen.
Die EU und der Schweiz. Weil da, also wenn wir wenn wir da das ein bisschen genau anschauen.
Alle Regelungen, also was für Pestizide man verwenden kann, was für Verpackungen man für eine Schokolade verwenden kann in in der Schweiz. Sind genau gleich wie die diversen Standards in der EU
Das bedeutet, dass ein ein Schweizer Produzent kann dann seine Lebensmittel nach die EU exportieren,
ohne Kontrollen an der Grenze und dann das bedeutet dann komplett ohne Schwierigkeiten, ohne Problemen. Also sowas wäre.
Rettung für die britische Lebensmittelindustrien, die zur Zeit unter dieser sehr schwierigen Bedingungen bei der Export dann so leiden.
Also das ist wo die jetzige Debatte ist. Also je,
ihren sind für, also wenn Dublin, meine ich, ja, es sind für so einen Vertrag, so so einen sogenannten sechzehn
Die EU hätte kein Problem, sowas abzuschließen, aber die EU kann sowas nicht vorschlagen.
Aber die britische Regierung,
gegen so war's, weil die wollen stattdessen ein Handelsvertrag zwischen Großbritannien und anderen Ländern der Welt. Und wenn die sowas mit der EU abschließen, es mache dann ein Handelsvertrag mit Australienote, die vor einigen Staaten deutlich schwieriger. Also das ist,
Das ist ein Punkt, wo man könnte irgendeine Lösung,
finden, was in den Interessen von beiden Seiten wäre. Äh aber das.
Es gibt ein bisschen eine eine Debatte in Großbritannien, ob sowas möglich wäre oder sinnvoll wäre gerade. Aber diese Debatte beginnt äh erst jetzt. Also das ist das ist, wo ich sehe, dass es ein ein bisschen,
Bewegungen geben könnte in den kommenden Monat.
Ja, weil die EU natürlich auch ein Interesse daran hat, zum Beispiel die Transportdurchlässigkeit für Waren aus Irland vielleicht auch zu erleichtern. Derzeit ist es ja so, dass äh zahlreiche neue,
Verbindung in Betrieb genommen worden sind, die von Dublin und diesen Südhafen in Irland, was jetzt gerade.
Ja, ja.
Genau, die, glaube ich, drei oder vier neue Häfen in Frankreich jetzt anfahren, wo sie auch teilweise ein, zwei Tage unterwegs äh sind, ist aber trotzdem immer noch besser ist, als durch diese ja problematische Situation England, Dova Cale, äh
durchzufahren, ne.
Oh, und das bedeutet für die Häfen, besonders in in Hollyhead, Fischguard und und und. Ähm da drohen so
großen Problemen, also diese in diese Kleinstädten sind diese Fähreverbindungen sehr, sehr wichtig für die für die Wirtschaft in diese Städte,
es drohe dann, der im kompletten so Einbruch der der Feberverbindungen dort. Ja aber da gibt's auch.
Keine pragmatische Lösungen in Sicht, weil.
Besonders mit Frost, das neue Chef unter Verhandler auf der Britsche Seite.
Ist für so ein also das bedeutet es geht nicht um praktischen Lösungen, es geht um eine.
Etherologisch geprägte Unabhängigkeit Großbritanniens gegenüber die EU,
Also wenn wir, wenn wir das vergleichen, was Großbritannien jetzt aus Art zu Handelstaktik gegenüber die
die EU äh vorantreibt. Das ist ganz anders als das Vorgehensweise von der Schweiz oder von Norwegen. Also in dieser anderen,
nicht EU, aber.
An der Grenze zu der EU Länder, wie wie Schweiz und Norwegen. Gab's immer diese so Konflikt zwischen Wille der Bevölkerung unabhängig zu sein? Und.
Praktische daran, dass das diverse diverse Unternehmen in den diversen Länder brauchten noch einen guten.
Pragmatischen Zugang zu den europäischen Markt. Also das war gob den Kompromiss in diese andere Länder. In Großbritannien ist es nur,
ideologisch geprägt. So möglichst unabhängig, auch wenn das problematisch ist für britischen Firmen, also das macht
aus meiner Sicht überhaupt kein Sinn und das kann man auch nicht rechtfertigen mit was die zugestimmt haben
in den in dem Referendum niemand hat so gesagt was für eine Art Brexit man haben man haben muss. Also ist eine Großbritannien und die britische Regierung,
Unterstützen noch eine sehr, sehr radikale Brexit-Variante. Ähm und da haben wir.
Kaum Änderungen gesehen, kaum Pragmatismus, äh ähm seit Dezember.
Zumal ja in den ganzen äh also vor der Wahl äh eigentlich mehrheitlich alle pro Brexit, also alle Befürworter gesagt haben, niemand will aus dem Single Market raus, ne, also das das stand überhaupt nicht im Vordergrund.
Genau, ähm und es ist nicht nur raus aus den Single Market, sondern auch,
pragmatische Brückenlösungen, wie wie eine, also so eine auch eine temporäre Vertrag, so äh Lebensmittelstandards.
Das lehnt die jetzige Regierung komplett ab, komplett. Ähm äh also es ist so,
ideologische radikal. Äh es ist kaum fassbar.
Schauen wir doch vielleicht mal auf die Situation in Nordirland, weil um das nochmal zu rekapitulieren, wer das noch nicht so ganz äh mit
hat, durch den Brexit-Vertrag, den Johnson letzten Endes ausgehandelt hat, ist ja im Prinzip gesagt worden, ja okay, wir gehen zwar hier aus allem raus, aber um das Karfreitagsabbau
kommen, den Friedensvertrag zwischen Nordirland, Großbritannien, EU, ähm denen irgendwie äh aufrechtzuerhalten
der ja sicherstellen soll, dass Nordirland uneingeschränkten und grenzlosen Zugang zu der Republik Irland hat, um das sicherzustellen, muss es dann im Prinzip
eine Kontrollgrenze geben,
in der RFC, also zwischen den Inseln Irland und den Insel Großbritannien. Sprich, wenn Waren von ähm Schottland oder England oder Wales nach Nordirland gefahren werden, dann gilt dort im Prinzip ein
ein ähnliches Grenzregime wie eben zur EU. Weil faktisch ist Nordirland.
Unterliegt weiterhin den wirtschaftlichen EU-Regeln, aber es ist natürlich nach wie vor Teil des Staatsgebietes von UK, was bedeutet, dass sich quasi äh das Vereinigte
Königreich eine Grenze geschaffen hat, völlig absurd, ne?
Genau. Aber grundsätzlich, Boris Johnson hat in der Öffentlichkeit,
nie akzeptiert, dass diese Grenze überhaupt existiert.
Der hat immer die Notirischen versprochen, ja als romantischer Kontrollen gibt es ja vielleicht schon, aber niemand will eine Grenze zwischen Nordirland von Großbritannien
Aber alle Experten haben gesagt, Moment mal, also das das geht einfach nicht. Ohne Kontrollen.
Und es herrschte dann seit dem,
unterschreiben von dem sogenannten Trading am vierundzwanzigsten Dezember. Es herrscht an einer immer größere Kritik.
Nordirland, also das es lohnt sich das ein bisschen mehr zu beobachten. Also grobe, es geht um zwei,
Verträge. Also den vorherigen Vertrag.
Also grob, zugestimmt in Oktober zwanzig neunzehn in Kraft treten Januar
zwanzig zwanzig, das hieß also, dem Teil von von den Austrittsvertrag um den Karfreitagsabkommen und keine harte Grenze.
In Nordirland sicherzustellen. Ja, also das bedeutet, keine Kontrollen an der Grenze zwischen Irland und Nordirland. Also aus diesem. Dann kommt dann dazu natürlich die Frage.
Was wäre überhaupt zu kontrollieren? Es hängt davon ab natürlich. Inwiefern EU-Regeln.
In Großbritannien noch respektiert sind,
Und das ist dann dieses, diese Spannung zwischen den, dem Trading Corporation Agreement. Also dieses Vertrag von den vierundzwanzigsten Dezember äh ähm letztes Jahr.
Nimmt Großbritannien so weit raus aus die europäische äh so regulatorische Sphäre. Das fand ich alles,
besonders Lebensmittel,
kontrolliert werden. Also das bedeutet, dass es also und wir hören der Zeit in der Britische Debatte und besonders von nordirischen Politiker. Ja, also
dieses ähm ähm das geht nicht mehr. Wir brauchen eine andere Lösung. Aber.
Das ist ja keine Lösung, weil dieses Problem betrifft nicht nur Nordengland, sondern dem kompletten Brexit-Paket. Ja, also was bedeutet oh und
es ist man hat wie wir schon was vor so zehn Minuten debattiert haben. Es gibt diese.
Grace Periots für die Kontrollen von Güter bei der Einreise in Dow, ja?
Die Dame ab Juli,
nicht mehr in Kraft sind. Also was bedeutet Großbritannien muss die Waren kontrollieren.
Grenze oder zwischen Nordirland und und im West von Großbritannien herrscht zurzeit,
genau das gleiche Problem. Wenn ich als zum Beispiel als Supermarkt, wenn ich will ein Wurst aus Schottland nach Not, Irland exportieren,
Gibt es zurzeit keine Kontrollen. Wenn ich dann dieses Wurst dann weiterhin nach Irland exportiere.
Dieses Wurst wird dann in in Irland importiert, ohne Kontrolle, weil es an der Grenze Notirland Irland keine Kontrollen gibt? Man könnte dann weiterhin nach Frankreich exportiert werden, auch ohne Kontrollen.
Aber so ein Wurstmuster, wenn ich sowas direkt aus England exportiere, dann nach Frankreich über Calais, muss es in dann eine Kontrolle geben. Ja, ich hoffe, das erklärt GoP,
wo dieses Ding kein Kämpfer, diese Spannung. Also was die EU dann sagt, ist.
So kann es dauerhaft nicht weitergehen. Großbritannien. Ihr habt
in so in zwanzig neunzehn, Anfang zwanzig zwanzig. Diese Note Protokoll unterschrieben. Unter anderem am vierundzwanzigsten Dezember zwanzig zwanzig äh einundzwanzig sorry
Trading Corpation Agreement ähm äh abgestimmt. Das bedeutet man muss.
Bestimmte Waren bei der Einreise in Nordirland kontrollieren. Also das.
Das kann nicht anders gehen. Und die politischen, die Briten sagen dagegen, nee, also das geht nicht, das ist unakzeptabel.
Aber die Briten bieten hier oder schlagen keine Lösungen vor. Ähm.
Es gibt eine Reihe von Problemen, muss zum Beispiel DHL-Pakete von England nach Nordirland,
äh brauchen die dann äh eine so ein Zoll äh Formular, ja, weil eine Exporte aus Großbritannien nach Deutschland.
Braucht sowas schon, aber nach nur Irland nicht. Ähm äh für Leute, die in Nordirland leben und in
Irland arbeiten oder umgekehrt. Wie diese sogenannten, gäbe es irgendeine Art eine eine Lösung für,
für diese Berufe. Also es gibt eine Riesenliste an praktischen Problemen zwischen Nordirland und Irland und zwischen Nordirland und den Rest von Großbritannien
Diese Probleme sind auf eine Seite praktisch und praktisch schwierig und manchmal teuer zu beheben und die sind auch,
höchstproblematisch, politisch gesehen, weil die die die das größte politische Partei,
auf der junioristische sozusagen die Protestanten in in Nordirland, die Nordirischen hat Brexit unterstützt, aber Brexit trennt jetzt.
Aber,
dann so eine Trennung zwischen Nordirland und den Rest von Großbritannien. Und das bedeutet dann die UP setzt sich dann ein für eine,
bschaffung von der aber sowas brauche dann eine Einführung von eine harte Grenze zwischen Nordirland.
Irland und sowas ist komplett nicht nur von Dublin, sondern auch für die EU komplett unakzeptabel.
Sodass bedeutet, dass es gibt zur Zeit keine einfache Lösungen in Sicht,
Es gibt natürlich andere politische Parteien, die schlagen dann pragmatischen Lösungen vor, weniger zu kontrollieren, längere Fristen für die Einführung von Kontrollen. Diese Arten von Lösungen. Aber diese Arten von Lösungen kommen.
In London überhaupt nicht voran. Also es gebe Lösungen, aber nur, wenn die britische Regierung.
Social-Lösungen sucht oder überhaupt solche Lösungen äh implementieren will. Und das braucht politische Wille und
Kompromiss auf der Seite vom Politiker in in Nordirland. Und das bringt uns dann zu den, also die die Pro,
Brexit, juninistische Partei Nordirland. Also
für die war die ehemalige Parteichefinchefin Aline Forster vergleichsweise pragmatisch, aber der neue Parteichef Edwing Puts der ist deutlich radikaler, also der hätte überhaupt kein Problem,
der Wiedereinführung von von Grenzkontrollen zwischen Nordirland und Irland zum Beispiel. Ähm also die die politische Situation ist äh ist überhaupt nicht gut
ähm äh in Nordirland gerade.
Kannst nochmal kurz ähm skizzieren, wie eigentlich die Regierungssituation in Nordirland sich derzeit
darstellt, weil die DOP war ja mit Aline Fosta ähm während der Zeit von Theresa May quasi in der britischen Regierung mit dabei oder hat sie zumindest toleriert
aber welche welche Macht hat sie denn effektiv derzeit in Nordirland?
So ähm supt ist ein gab's so eine keine formelle Koalitionsregierung zwischen die UP und die in die konservativen aber die.
Die OP war dabei, bei aller Abstimmung im Britischen Rundhaus haben die die Theresa May in die konservativen Unterstützt. Und Theresa May ist Brexit-Variante damals und stürzt, weil.
Diese Vorschlag wäre
deutlich einfacher gewesen für Nordirland als die Boris Johnson Variante. Also Boris Johnson hat grob eine Brexit-Variante vorgeschlagen, wo dem Brexit
Härter wäre für Großbritannien. Ja, so England, Wesenschall an und schwieriger, als meine diese.
Eine Trennung oder oder Spaltung zwischen Nordirland und den Rest von Großbritannien
Das war dann den Grund, warum keine Politikschicker aus Nordirland Boris Johnsons Brexit-Variante überhaupt unterstützt haben, die,
war schon im Herbst zwanzig neunzehn schon total sauer,
Dann kam dem Brötchen Unterhauswahl Dezember zwanzig neunzehn. Großes für die conserteteam. Und dann verlor die GOP komplett alles in in Westminster, also die sind jetzt in Westminster,
nicht mehr relevant. Die regieren noch in Nordirland, in so einer Powersharing Agreement,
zwischen.
Mit dem First Minister äh zusammen mit und es gibt Wahlen in Nordirland. Nächstes Jahr. Also was.
Grob, also das einzige Angebot an den zur Zeit aus London ist.
Kontrollen bei der Einreise von Güter.
Möglichst weit zu verschieben, damit die Einführung von wahren Kontrollen an der Hafen von äh von Belfast sorry erst.
Ähm nach der Wahl in Nordirland zwanzig zweiundzwanzig in Kraft treten. Aber sowas ist aus der Sicht der EU
Keine gute Lösung, weil die Ewer zugesagt, hey Moment mal, also so eine lange Übergangsfest können wir nicht tolerieren. Also was ist ihr Problem da, äh Großbritannien?
Ihr implementiert nicht, was wir schon zwanzigneunzehn ähm abgeschlossen haben. Also das ist Grob die die Situation. Es
allinfaste es nicht mehr die UP Parteichef, aber er ist immer noch
Minister in in Nordirland und wird, soweit wir wissen,
mittelfristig dieses Amt noch behalten. Aber die die Macht etwas.
In Sachen Brexit zu lösen liegt nicht bei dem sondern.
Das heißt, niemand hat eigentlich in Nordirland wirklich einen Einfluss.
Genau und und niemand unterstützt den jetzigen Situation. Ja, also will ein Verein für sie ihr Land,
den notirischen TUP, die wollen keine Kontrollen zwischen Großbritannien und Nordi, Irland. Und wenn dem Preis dafür ist die wieder Einführung von Kontrollen an der Grenze zwischen Nordirland und Irland
könnten die dann akzeptieren. Die eher pragmatischeren wie den die verlieren an Wähler.
Ein bisschen, aber verlieren viele Wähleranzüge, die sogenannten Alarms Party, also das ist eine Party, eine Partei
zwischen Nationisten und Juniisten gewinnen enorm an Unterstützung zur Zeit, weil die versuchen pragmatische Lösungen zu finden, um diese Problemen.
Großen Teils zu beheben. Zum Beispiel.
Der erste Partei in Großbritannien überhaupt in Großbritannien, der für Großbritannien und EU war.
War diese Allianz Party in Nordirland. Also die sind
echt gut, aber die haben eine Unterstützung von noch unter zwanzig Prozent der Notirische Bevölkerung. Aber die die politische Situation in in Nordirland ist zur Zeit.
Alles ist blockiert und fast alle sind, oh haben das Gefühl, dass sie machtlos sind.
Wie könnte denn eine Wahl in Nordirland ausgehen?
Also nach den jetzigen Situationen wäre es mit Shintainers Gurs des Partei.
Wenige Stimmen für die Junioristen und dann mit einer deutlich höhere Beteiligung von ähm.
Von den Party als vorher der Situation war. Aber das könnte dann bedeuten
dann ein first Minister von. Also das wäre ein sehr wichtigen Schritt in Richtung so ein vereinigtes Irland. Aber wäre sowas überhaupt
friedlich hinzukriegen. Also grob äh es herrscht,
so eine gewisse Unruhe in Westminster und die Leute, die am.
So die diese Situation näher beobachten. Aber für die konservativen muss man auch noch sagen, ist die Situation in Nordirland,
grob egal. Ja, es gibt es ist nur eine Minderheitliche Position innerhalb der konservativen Partei überhaupt konkrete Lösungen für Notirland zu finden. Ähm.
Es gibt
zum Beispiel der der der ähm der Sprecher der Not, der ich Ausschuss für Nordirland, dem britischen Unterhaus. Ähm Simon Hohe heißt er von den Konservativen. Der versteht diese ganze diese ganzes Problematik. Aber
seine Partei hat sehr sehr wenig Wille überhaupt diese diese Problemen zu beheben.
Würde denn, also wie ist denn das mit der Regierung geregelt gerade in Nordirland? Gibt es im Rahmen des Karfreitagsabkommen noch dieses Power-Sharing, was immer stattfinden muss?
Genau. Ja.
Und wie wie schlägt sich das konkret nieder?
Ja also ähm also das bedeutet also ich ich muss sagen, ich bin kein Spezialist in wie äh,
wie das genau geht und wie man das aufteilt. Aber es ist traditionell, dass im und den Minister dann,
Die beiden Seiten der der politische Streit in Nordirland. So, eine kommt von einer Seite, der andere von dem anderen Seite. Was immer der Fall.
War bisher war die.
Die Junioristen, also die Protestanten hatten Minister und den stellvertretende.
War dann von so der andere Seite, also die Junioristen, ja, so die die Katholiken.
Du meinst die Republikaner, also.
Ja genau, ja, also, aber dieses, diese Situation könnte dann kippen, wenn die.
Wenn die die Junioristen verlieren an Unterstützung, an,
unabhängigen Parteien wie Alleinsparty. Also ähm es könnte dann sein, zwanzig zweiundzwanzig, man hätte dann,
Shimphane als größtes Partei in dem nordirischen Sembly, was man bisher nie.
Hatte.
Und ist das ein Signal, also man hat das denkst du, dass das eine Bedeutung hätte?
Ja, also äh symbolisch schon. Ja, ähm inwiefern.
Auch dann friedlich zu lösen wäre, ist auch natürlich eine interessante Frage, ja. Ähm aber es ist wirklich ein großes Problem. Es gibt.
Es gibt ein sehr tiefes Problem für sagen wir pragmatische.
Junioristen. Ja, in in Nordirland. Also die, die für ein verreinigtes Königreich sind, das Nordirland bleibt aus Teil.
Von UK, aber.
Die wollen auch eine friedliche Situation an der Grenze so Irland und unterstützen noch den Karfreitagsabkommen. Also diese so pragmatisches.
Starb in den letzten Jahren aus,
Also das bedeutet, manche von diesen Menschen gingen zu den Unabhängigen unserer Party und manche anderen,
sind etwas die Radikale geworden und die diese eher pragmatischere Partei der Partei also ein bisschen
pragmatische, aus den, von Forstern Puts, Givan, nicht Givan so unbedingt an Unterstützung, aber Position wäre
es ist radikaler geworden. Also das bedeutet, man sah eine Radikalisierung.
Der Junioristen in in Nordirland. Äh also mit mittelfristig könnte das dann ein Problem sein für die,
die sie so per Powersharing und für pragmatische Lösungen für das nordirische Komplex.
Wie muss man denn diese die Mehrheiten überhaupt einschätzen? Gerade im Hinblick
darauf, dass es ja immer noch im Raum steht und vom Karfreitag-Abkommen ja auch explizit vorgesehen ist, dass wenn sich abzeichnet, dass es gegebenenfalls eine Mehrheit geben könnte für den Beitritt Nordirlands zur Republik Irland, dass ja dann auch eine Abstimmung ermöglich
werden soll.
Ja, äh das ist ja schwierig, weil es gibt.
Langsam steigender Unterstützung für einen.
Für ein verreinigtes Irland langsam. Aber die.
Minderheit von sehr radikalen Junioristen lehnen sowas so definitiv ab. Das wäre es möglich, so was.
Überhaupt friedlich hinzukriegen. Da bin ich nicht sicher.
Also das ist dann meine Förchtung. Ähm also das bedeutet, dass den Weg so ein Verein ist nicht einfach. Also das bedeutet, es wird lange Zeit dauern. Ist auch ein Problem.
Für Dublin, weil nur die Irland ist ein Drittel.
Pro Kopf ärmer als als die nirischen Republik.
Also das bedeutet, man hat man hält sich da aus so einer, so einer deutsche Wiedevereinigungsproblem irgendwie
Also das bedeutet das, obwohl politisch gibt's eine große Unterstützung in Dublin für ein vereintes Irland. Viele Politiker da wissen, dass es wäre nicht einfach so was hinzukriegen. Also grob.
Auch aus meiner Sicht die Lösung wäre und das ist, was die EU jetzt auferstanden hat, wäre.
Die jetzigen Problemen pragmatisch zu lösen. Die wahren.
Möglichst wenig Waren bei der Einreise nur die ihr Laden zu kontrollieren, aber man muss akzeptieren, dass manche Dingen müssen kontrolliert werden, dass.
Alles friedlich bleibt an der Grenze zu Nordirland. Ja, also faktisch,
so pragmatische Lösungen für die alltäglichen Problemen zu finden. Also das ist die Linie der EU, das ist die Linie von Dublin, das ist die Linie von Lions Party. Man muss auch sagen, das ist die Linie von der Labour Partei in in London, obwohl die das
gar nicht äußern, weil die, die, die keine klare Position äh in, in, in diese ganze Brexit-Problematik äußern wollen. Aber.
Die meisten Akteuren sehen das dem Stateus oder dem vorherigen States Quaro.
Obwohl dies nicht ideal ist, alle anderen Optionen, sie sind schlimmer. Aber diese Position.
Hat keine große Unterstützung von nordirischen Juniisten und keine besondere Unterstützung von Frost oder von Boris Johnson.
Und die Republik Irland sieht halt potentiell damit auch irgendwie eher Probleme auf sich äh.
Ja Möglichkeit, auch Möglichkeiten, eine Mischung aus Möglichkeiten und, und, und, und, und Problemen.
Ja. Gut, dann äh lass uns mal wegkommen von Nord,
Irland zu dem zweiten Konflikt her, der sich ja jetzt auch ein bisschen verschärft hat und wir hatten ja bei der letzten Sendung auch schon gesagt, lass uns mal wieder ein Update machen, wenn es zu den
schottischen Wahlen kommt, die sind jetzt äh gewesen, also in Schottland wurden äh wurde das Parlament neu gewählt und damit im Prinzip auch,
Minister, also die Regierung neu bestimmt. Da gab's dann relativ wenig Überraschungen, nämlich die.
Partei
von äh Nikola Stergin, also die Scottis National Party, die zwar, ja, sich nationalistisch nennt, aber halt äh eigentlich eher im sozialliberalen Spektrum aufgestellt ist
die ähm auch jetzt die letzten Jahre eben schon regiert hat, die hat auch wieder gewonnen, hat glaube ich einen Sitz zugewonnen,
ein bisschen weniger ist, als sie sich erhofft haben, weil hätten sie noch einen weiteren Sitz gewonnen, dann hätten sie erstmalig die oder wieder mal die äh äh absolute Mehrheit
geworden. Nichtsdestotrotz
ähm zusammen mit den Grünen, die auch relativ gut abgeschnitten haben, haben sie weitaus die Mehrheit, werden also wahrscheinlich weiter eine Koalition bilden, wie sie es bisher schon gemacht haben,
und damit zeichnet sich Prinzip, wenn man an dieser Wahl mal fest macht, wie so der generelle Trend ist, äh ab die Schotten,
sind mehrheitlich,
unterstützen mehrheitlich eine Parteienkonstellation, die offiziell für ein neues Referendum eintritt, zur Loslösung von Großbritannien.
Ja. Ähm ja, das ist eine sehr faire Zusammenfassung. Ähm man muss auch sagen, die.
Periode vor der Wahl war für die SNP sehr problematisch, weil es gab diese Spannung zwischen Parteichef Stergen und den Ex-Parteichef
der seine eigene Partei gegründet hatte mit der Name Alba ähm.
Also äh den Einfluss auf der Wahl und Alber gewann keine Sitze, aber,
irgendwie dieses Idee, das den sehr einheitlich ist und und und.
Zusammensteht. Da stellte man so die Frage,
Ist es überhaupt eine einheitliche Bewegung noch? Äh also vor der Wahl. Also das hatte eine einen deutlichen Einfluss auf der
so war vorbereitet oder die Wahlkampfphase. Ähm,
und natürlich es gab so eine gewisse.
Also das bedeutet, dass in manche Wahlkreise.
Wähler haben, konservative Kandidaten und Stützt und besonders Konservativen haben,
Kandidaten unterstützt in den Wahlkreisen um dann diese Position so der Junioristen.
Ein bisschen zu stärken. Also das das war das waren dann die Gründe für dieses Ergebnis,
es war nicht so den Hammer Ergebnis, was die SNP gehofft haben, aber ein Plus von einem Sitz für die SNP, ein Plus von zwei,
für die, für die Grünen und ähm minus eins äh für die minus zwei,
für Labour, also und keine Änderungen für die für die Conservety. Also keine große Änderungen, ein klares Mehrheit für die, für die Pro-Unabhängigkeit Parteien.
Man muss dazu sagen, dass dass das Wahlsystem ja sich äh unterscheidet von dem wie es in äh gesamt Großbritannien,
ist. Man hat ja äh das ist ja quasi also sozusagen so das Mehrheitswahlrecht in den einzelnen ähm,
Ist ja alleinig für die Zusammensetzung des äh Gesamtparlaments erforderlich und in Schottland ist es eigentlich eher so, wie es bei uns ist, dass es sich eben auch aus dem prozentualen Anteil der Partei
noch zusätzlich zusammensetzt.
Aber es ist wie die Situation in Deutschland ohne Übergangsübergangsmandate.
Mhm, okay.
Also das bedeutet, dass es nicht so komplett proportional ist, ähm und es ist nicht so fünfzig, fünfzig Wahlkreise und Listen, sondern etwa sächsisch vierzig. Also es ist ähm äh also.
Das bedeutet, es ist besser als die Situation Investments, aber nicht komplett proportional. Ähm.
Man muss auch sagen, ist auch zu den Ergebnissen.
Es ist sehr, sehr interessant, auch aus deutscher Sicht, dass der der ehemalige Chef der SNP.
Im Londoner Parliment, anges Robinson, eins von den absolut klugesten Menschen der SNP ist jetzt im schottischen Parlament, er hat seinen Sitz im Adam gewonnen. Also was bedeutet das, eins von den.
So brilliantesten Denker der.
Im Parlament vertreten. Also das ist ein sehr sehr positives Zeichen für die für die SNP. Also der wird so ein Schlüsselperson sein.
Für die zukünftige Debatte zum Thema Unabhängigkeit,
und Zukunftsbeziehungen zwischen Schottland und andere Länder der EU. Ähm der wird bestimmt in den deutschen Medien, in den nächsten Monaten und Jahren auftreten, weil er auch ähm fließend Deutsch,
ähm also ist echt ein sehr, sehr kluger Typ und also dass er wieder dabei ist, äh das ist etwas aus meiner Sicht sehr, sehr positiv ist für WS and p.
Aber der steht auch klar äh für die Unabhängigkeit von Schottland.
Ja klar, also die Frage ist jetzt nicht.
Opti, die SNP im Grünen wollen so eine Referendum.
Organisieren, das wollen die dann machen. Die Frage ist wie, wann.
Und welche Bedingungen. Äh und da haben wir haben wir.
Kein großes Klarheit. Wir müssen sagen, dass diese Spannung zwischen Nickel und und Ex-Parteichef Alex Sament ist nicht nur eine persönliche Spannung, sondern auch eine,
diverse taktische Überlegungen, also wir wollen,
ein langes Spiel, wenn es braucht, ein paar Jahren, bis Schottland unabhängig ist, können wir damit leben.
Es gibt andere Menschen, besonders sammelnd ähm äh aber.
Auch innerhalb der SMP, die sagen, nein. Ähm die Situation ist schon so ernst, Boris Johnson äh ist noch an der Macht in in London.
Wir müssen möglichst schnell eine Unabhängigkeitsreferendum,
in in Schottland machen. Die grob zusammengefasst, die Pragmatisten haben diese Diskussion größtenteils so gewonnen. Also das bedeutet, dass ich vermute.
Also eine Referendum dieses Jahr wird es nicht geben. Nächstes Jahr ist auch eher unwahrscheinlich. Also es wird ein Referendum geben in.
Vielleicht zwei, drei Jahren. Dann erreichen wir dann die zweite Frage. Ist wie.
Wie könnte man überhaupt so ein Referendum organisieren? Also.
Dieses Referendum zwanzig vierzehn da mit äh mit dem damaligen Premierminister verhandelt und die haben zusammen so eine legale.
Weg gefunden, um dieses Referendum zu ermöglichen, weil normalerweise um so einen Referendum zu organisieren, brauche man die Zustimmung dem von dem Britischen Unterhaus. Ja, also.
Es ist nicht eine alleine eine Entscheidung nur für Schottland. Die Situation ist jetzt,
Aus zwei Gründen anders. Erstens in zwanzig vierzehn in den Meinungsumfragen.
Gab's nur dreißig Prozent Unterstützung für Unabhängigkeit. Es ist jetzt bei fünfzig bis fünfundfünfzig Prozent.
Und zweitens damals war an der Macht, der war größtenteils ein Pragmatist und jetzt hat man Boris Johnson, der so krass ideologisch ist.
Und er sagt, er auf keinen Fall,
die die Schotten, ein, ein, ein, ein Referendum zulassen. Dazu gesagt, das war eine einmalige Chance, zwanzigvierzehn, warum sollen wir dann ein zweites Referendum dann organisieren?
Die Schaden sagen, hey Moment mal, also so geht es nicht, weil damals war Großbritannien noch in der EU die Situation ist dann heute
anders. Also wir wollen in der EU bleiben. Also das bedeutet, dass wir haben jetzt einen zusätzlichen Grund, unabhängig zu werden. Also die Situation ist anders aus dem zwanzig vierzehn,
Also wir haben keine endgültige Lösung wie könnte man dieses Problem dann,
was ist die Lösung für dieses Problem.
Könnte man einen Kompromiss finden, damit London so eine Referendum zulässt? Oder machen die Schotten das dann trotzdem? Und im schlimmsten Falle, man erreiche dann eine Situation, die in Katalonien, wo London akzeptiert, dann.
In ja, so dass die die machen irgendwann eine Inoffizielle Referendum irgendwie.
Aber das würde ja Nicholas Dirgen gar nicht wollen, sowas.
Nee, das will sie nicht, aber das ist genau dem Streitparteien, der ein parteiinternen, bei dem Nationalisten ist.
Nikolas ist bereit, ein bisschen Zeit zu nehmen, das alles zu recherchieren, die Wege zu finden, sie will keinen Konflikt mit Westminster, aber sie weiß natürlich, dass Boris Johnson.
Könnte man sagen insgesamt aber besonders, wenn es geht um schottischen Unabhängigkeit ist überhaupt nicht zu vertrauen,
Also das ist dann eine Kernfrage für die für die schottischen Nationisten. Ähm also das ist dann äh warum ich.
Warum es alles zur Zeit so ruhig ist, aber ich erwarte, dass zum Beispiel im Herbst dieses Jahr, wenn die Pandemie größtenteils hoffentlich vorbei ist, dann
brechen diese Arten von Fragen dann wieder aus und gewinnen dann an Bedeutung. Nicht nur in Edinburgh, sondern auch in London. Und London hat.
Keine Lösung. Äh also Boris Johnson sagt ja, wir investiere mehr in Schottland. Aber so äh ja, also äh.
Könnte man machen, aber äh das kommt bei den Schotten nicht gut an. Das ist so eine Art, ja, also da das man hat den Eindruck, dass man man.
Käuft die schottische Wähler irgendwie. Ähm also das bedeutet, dass es gibt.
Kein Plan in London, außer ja, wir lassen die die Unabhängigkeitsreferendum nicht zu.
So es ist keine großen guten Gedanken.
Keine Kompromisslösungen, es herrschte auch in anderen Themenfelder Streit zwischen Schottland und London im Bereich der Pandemiebekämpfung, Fischerei, Politik und,
Brexit, ähm äh es gibt eine herrschende Streit im Bereich der Agrarpolitik. Also das bedeutet es.
Wenn beiden Seiten für einen Kompromiss wären, könnte man vielleicht einen Kompress finden, aber aber.
Diese dieses Kompromiss ist sozusagen überhaupt nicht in Sicht. Ähm und da das ist, was macht diese ganze Situation so so.
So sehr spannend, aber auch gleichzeitig irgendwie deprimierend auf der Westminster Seite.
Ich würde gerne mal so ein bisschen auch äh aus der Perspektive schauen
angenommen, es gäbe ein Referendum und ähm Schottland würde sich tatsächlich jetzt ähm für den Austritt aus UK und damit ja implizit auch für einen neuen Beitritt in die EU
entscheiden. Das klingt ja erstmal jetzt ganz romantisch so, ja die Völker sind selbstbestimmt et cetera PP, aber praktisch,
Gibt's natürlich dann auch eine ganze Menge Probleme. Mal so ein bisschen durchgegangen. Äh das erste Problem ist natürlich.
Man hat jetzt hier eine vierhundert Jahre alte offene Grenze mit England.
Ja, mit offenen Ländern, et cetera und schafft sich damit eigentlich eine ähnliche Situation, wie man sie auch in Nordirland hat. So, dass Leute wollen ja da nicht sozusagen auf einmal einen Grenzzaun gezogen sehen
aber das würde halt zwangsläufig irgendwie kommen müssen.
Genau und ja und da vor der der schottischen Parlamentswahl gab's viele.
Muss ich auch sagen, na idiotische Meinungen von pro Unabhängigkeitspolitiker. Ja, wir die Grenze ist auf keinen Fall ein Problem. Nee, das stimmt ja nicht. Schau mal, wie es an der Notirische Grenze ist. Aber
auf der so schottische englische Grenze.
Die so Geographie ist da nicht so schwierig wie an der irischen notirischen Grenze. Es geht etwa zwanzig Grenzübergänge in ihrer Notirland gibt's über vierhundert. Ähm,
und es gibt kaum, so Städte oder oder Bauernhöfe, die.
Auf beiden Seiten der Grenze sind. Also das bedeutet das.
Von dem praktischen Standpunkt. Es ist vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher, so wenn es, wenn es käme, so Kontrollen.
Sowas zu machen. Aber natürlich wirtschaftlich gesehen ist die Integration zwischen Schottland und dem Rest von Großbritannien.
Noch, die sind ja noch tiefer integriert, als Notirland und im Preis von Großbritannien. Also die wirtschaftlichen Schaden wären
noch schwieriger zu zu lösen. Ich weiß, dass die Schotten haben begonnen, ein bisschen zu untersuchen, diese diese faire Verbindungen, die du vorher erläutert hattest zwischen Dublin und Rosslay und und französischen Häfen.
Könnte man sowas einführen zwischen Rosa in der Nähe von Edinburgra und Holland oder oder Sibrige. Ähm
ich hatte auch ein paar lustige Diskussionen, könnte man so Durchgangsgütezüge durch den Kanaltunnel ohne Zwischenhalt in England für Gütezüge von Edinburgh nach.
Paris. Ja, ein bisschen nach dem Grat äh Durchgang durch Litauen nach Russland zum Beispiel.
Oder so Transitstrecke zwischen DDR und äh Berlin.
Ja genau, sowas in der Art, ja, also ähm äh solche Arten von Diskussionen, grob, groben zusammengefasst, es gibt eine enorme Reihe an Problemen, ähm.
Aber es ist nicht das, wenn Schottland bleibt in die.
Jetzige Situation. Das ist keine Problemen gibt. Also wirtschaftlich gesehen.
Schottland, besonders dem Fischereiindustrie, in Schottland ist von dieses Brexit hart betroffen. Ähm politisch gesehen,
Die konservativen in London haben null Bock, gute pragmatische Lösungen für Schottland zu finden, keine so Power-Sharing-Lösungen oder oder sonstiges
Ach so, die das bedeutet, dass es gibt keine ideale Lösung in Sicht.
Und das ist.
Wo es jetzt hier hakt. Es es wird dann so eine sehr ideologische Diskussion. Es so eine Art.
Wie wird Schottland regiert.
Im gibt's in London, überhaupt guten Lösungen für für Problemen in Schottland, eher nicht.
Ähm auch Labour hat keine gute Lösungen für Schottland, weil Labo keine gute Lösung für Brexit insgesamt hat. Also die Lösung wäre bestimmt so eine federale Großbritannien, wo Schottland
mehr Macht kriegen könnte zum Beispiel,
Sowas wäre vielleicht ein Versuch wert, aber das lehnen die Konservativen auch ab. Ähm was wir zumindest erwarten von dem,
von die schottische Regierung. Es ist erneut
einen kompletten Plan für die Unabhängigkeit. Also dieses Papier vom vor dem zwanzig vierzehner Referenten, also sieben bis achthundert Seiten, wie funktioniere
einen unabhängigen Schottland. Es war ein echt ein gutes Papier, also deutlich besser als alles, was die britische Regierung je produziert hat, äh in in Sachen Brexit
Also ich erwarte sowas äh sowas ähnliches von den Schotten und hoffentlich mit so einer realistische,
Analyse, von wo die Problemen sind und wie man die am besten behebt. Ähm ja, ähm.
Und natürlich, so einen harten Brexit ist ein Problem für dich Schotten, ja, weil mit einem sanften Brexit wäre schottisches Unabhängigkeit deutlich einfacher, klar.
Also letzten Endes, ich höre halt immer wieder die das beste Argument für die SNP, für ein Referendum ist Boris Johnson, solange er da sozusagen seine
fortsetzt, dann ähm spielt das alles nur in deren Karten und auch der Widerstand gegen ein Referendum an sich,
wird mehr oder weniger direkt dazu führen, dass dieser Support da ist. Letzten Endes wird's natürlich auch von den wirtschaftlichen Parametern nicht ganz unabhängig sein. Beim
Referendum war das ja noch so, dass man so in diesem Öl gelebt hat. So, wir produzieren ja viel Öl und damit war da ein Ölpreis war äh weit oben. Da sieht's jetzt ganz anders aus. Gut, äh Schottland ist auch bei.
Ähm Wind äh Energie zum Beispiel auch ziemlich weit vorne, aber damit kriegt man ja alleine so ein Land äh auch nicht gefahren, ne.
Das heißt, es muss eben auch eine eine,
geben und man ist eben da oben an der Peripherie jetzt auch nicht so wunderbar aufgestellt, wenn man darauf angewiesen ist, mehr oder weniger erstmal durch England äh zu fahren und äh ja am Ende sogar noch schwierigere Schiffswege zu haben als
Als Irland zur EU, ne.
Stimmt, dass all das stimmt vorkommen. Ähm ja, aber will.
Also grob dieses Argument ist die Regierungen in London und das muss sich auch zustimmen. Die Regierung seit,
zumindest fünfzehn Jahren vielleicht länger irgendwie die Villen äh der Schotten in Sachen EU.
In Sachen mehr Macht oder mehr so die Central, die will in der der Schotten.
Nee, nicht so respektiert hat. Also, dass dass dieses Argument ist.
Bis dann, kommt gut an in Schottland. Also, es gibt einen anderen Weg. In Schottland ist alles politisch ein bisschen anders. Ähm äh wir gehen unseren eigenen Weg. Ähm.
Dieses Argument ist so eine sehr ideologische ideologisches Argument, ethisches Argument ist kein pragmatisches Argument, ja. Ähm ich stelle dir zu, es ist.
Es wird ja schwierig sein, aber die politischen Situation in Großbritannien ist zur Zeit insgesamt schwierig.
Keine gute Lösungen in Sicht. Ja natürlich, also pragmatschaflich, rein wirtschaftlich pragmatisch macht, unabhängigkeit zur Zeit kein Sinn.
Aber das ist keine reine wirtschaftliche Lösung. Ja oder wirtschaftliches Argument.
Ähnliche Tendenzen gibt es ja jetzt auch in Wales. Und ich erinnere mich noch ganz gut als wir, glaube ich, hier angefangen haben über diese ganze Situation zu sprechen und auch mal die einzelnen äh Königreiche
durchgegangen sind, da,
war, glaube ich, so deine Position auch noch so, naja, also Wales und England, die sind für immer miteinander äh verkittet und das das das wird sich niemals trennen.
Bist du da immer noch so optimistisch?
Diese Emotion es ist ja schwierig ähm weil also wenn wir ähm.
Wenn die wer die Wahlergebnissen in in gab auch am gleichen Tag ein paar Immenswahl in in,
in in Wales. Und das war ein erstaunlich gutes Ergebnis für die Labour Partei dort. Ähm,
und obwohl die Anzahl an ähm an Tote in Wales.
Kaum anders ist als in in England oder in Schottland.
Also Covid, Covi.
Politisch kam Wales durch oder die walisische Regierung,
durch diese Pandemie relativ gut durch. Also ähm
der Premierminister und sein sein Gesundheitsminister haben klar mit den Menschen kommuniziert, die waren ehrlich,
man hat den Eindruck, die sind auf der Seite der Bürger, diese
katastrophalen Situationen, die es in sonst in London gab, also
Dominik und und und so in England gab's in Wales ja nicht. Ähm und.
Dann die die haben und dann irgendwie Labour in Wales hat sich so als Art.
Partei nicht für die Unabhängigkeit, aber zumindest die Partei für eine.
Andere Art, wie man regiert.
Sich so durchgesetzt in Wales. Also das bedeutet, man hat einen ganz anderen Ton, in wie wie Labour in Wales regiert, wie die Community.
Und das ist die irgendwie ein bisschen unabhängig von wie Labour in London.
Als Partei der Zeug agiert.
Es gab dann äh dagegen, obwohl es herrscht gerade in Wale, so ein bisschen so eine Po-unabhängigkeitsstimmung.
Und das auch in ungewöhnlichen Kreisen, ja, also sogar mein Vater, der aus England kommt und in Wales wohnt, ja
der könnte heutzutage vorstellen für einen unabhängigen zu stimmen. Also,
Das wäre vor fünf Jahren überhaupt nicht möglich. Vor äh sowas vorzustellen. Also da gibt's schon eine Änderung. Aber im Vergleich zu die Situation in Schottland.
Parteipolitisch kam, dass irgendwie nicht an. Also die haben immer noch Mehrheit, ich will Label gestimmt.
Also das ist wie dem valisischen.
Nie so wirklich an Bedeutung gewonnen. Also den ist noch so mehr für einen.
Halbwegs unabhängigen politischen Kultur, aber nicht komplett für Unabhängigkeit. Also das ist grob die Richtung.
Ähm also Wales wird dann weiterhin von Labour regiert ähm,
ohne großes Umbruch, ohne große große Schwierigkeiten
Die Zusammenarbeit zwischen Marc Drake für depremierminister Dortmund und Nikolain in Schottland, obwohl die von anderen Parteien kommen, ist sehr gut
Die Zusammenarbeit zwischen Drake Food und Boris Johnson ist natürlich sehr schlecht, weil niemand will einen Weg mit Boris Johnson so so kooperieren. Aber das ist grob zusammengefasst, äh die die Situation.
Das heißt, die Leberpartei in Wales ist eigentlich auch eher unionistisch geprägt.
So sage ich so wenn es nicht so genau.
Aber die es ist für so ist für ein föderales Großbritannien. Also wo nicht unabhängig
also so jungistisch in dem Sinne keine Unabhängigkeit, aber das Wales gewinnt mehr Macht.
Eigene Entscheidungen zu treffen in alle möglichen Themenbereichen, Gesundheitspolitik, Sozialpolitik,
Tour, Sport, Verkehr, also es gibt keinen kompletten Umplanung der Bahnsystem in Wales, also total vorangetrieben von dem walisischen Regierung zum Beispiel. Also
diese Arten von von in dieser Art von Politikfelder, da da will Labo mehr Verantwortung in Kader äh aber keinen kompletten Unabhängigkeit.
Also das steht noch ein bisschen aus, dass wir hier Bewegung, äh nennenswerter Art äh erleben werden. Ich denke, es spielt sich dann doch eigentlich alles eher erst mal in Schottland ab und das ist dann auch so.
Genau, das stimme ich vollkommen zu.
Entscheidend letzten Endes auch glaube ich für das Gesamtgemüt, weil ich denke, dieser mögliche Bruch von äh Schottland will das jetzt gar nicht weiter ausführen, aber das ist das, das, das hat natürlich eine Dimension, die im Prinzip.
Diese gesamte Vorstellung von UK eigentlich komplett bricht, während
Irland so ein bisschen außen vor ist, wäre halt Schottland dann schon so eine wichtige Farbe im äh Union Jack, die dann auf einmal fehlen würde. Und äh damit geht natürlich auch viel Selbstverständnis und Identität äh davon weg.
Ja, aber wir müssen auch nicht vergessen, dass es gibt auch enorme Spannungen in England.
Nicht nur zwischen England und die anderen drei Nationen. Ja. Und das haben wir auch bei dieser Reihe von von Wahlen,
gesehen, ja? Ähm,
und das dieses parteipolitische Landschaft in in England ist auch, sage ich nicht mal, so in einem totalen Umbruch, aber es zur Zeit in einer.
Sehr sage ich so ungewöhnliche Situation, ja? Und das hat einen enormen Einfluss auf dem Politic,
von Großbritannien gegenüber anderen Ländern der EU auch Außenpolitik des Landes. Und die Beziehung zwischen London und KF Edimbra und. Ja, ähm.
Ich zitiere da nur ein Beispiel davon. Also es gab ähm eine Nachwahl, so ein Boy-Election, ja, in ähm in.
Eine in ehemalige Industriestadt im Nordosten Englands, auch am gleichen Tag wie den ähm äh schottischen und valisischen Parlamentswahlen.
Und das war vorher ein Hochburg von Labour. Auch der sehr bekannte ähm äh ehemalige Minister aus Toni Players Seiten äh Peter Monderson war, war
war damals in der, in der Neunziger ähm äh Abgeordnete aus
Und der Abgeordnete da musste zurücktreten, gab's dieses Nachwahl und
Waren erstaunlicherweise mit einer überragenden Mehrheit die Konservativen. Ja, also,
Könnte es zustande kommen, dass die Konservativen gewinnen dann in so ein Wahlkreis.
Habe ich mich auch gefragt.
Das ist da müssen wir zurück den ähm.
Unterhaus, Wahl zwanzig neunzehn zurückgreifen, also in dem britischen.
Diskussion. Gibt's diese diesen Spruch, den also die so rote rotes Wand, ja, rote Wand. Ähm.
Das sind ehemalige.
Wahlkreise im Norden Englands, die dann mehrheitlich für den Brexit gestimmt haben.
Und seit dem Brexit-Referendum dann immer mehr für die Konservativen immer weniger für die Labour Partei gestimmt haben,
Mit siebzig Prozent für den EU-Austritt gestimmt und weil die konservativen jetzt.
Brexit-Partei sind, ja? Wäh wählen Städte, wie Hartnep,
immer mehr für die Konservativen. Das ist nicht nur
so für Westminstsitze, sondern auch auf andere Ebene. Also es es gab ein paar so Burgschafts
Wahlen in West Midlands und in zum Beispiel
Da gab's auch Mehrheiten in dieser ehemaligen Industrieregionen, Mehrheiten für die Konservativen dort und nicht für Label. Also Label verliert in diese ehemaligen Hochburgen. Es ist ein bisschen wie die Situation für die SPD in
in Deutschland, dass ehemaligen, also Arbeitsstätte, Industriestädte.
Wählen nicht mehr für so die für die Arbeiterpartei, ja? Ähm.
Und das ist natürlich ein Riesenproblem für Labels Parteichef Staarmar. Weil er hat alles darauf gewettet.
Gewinnen
Er hat einen Brexit-Kurs für Labour vorangetrieben. Er hat ein ähm er wollte Sitze wie
zurückerobern, hat überhaupt nicht äh hingekriegt. Ähm.
Er setzte sich mehr auf so eine halbwegs so nationalistische Orientierung der Partei. Aber das,
Das funktionierte nicht. Also wie wie dem ehemaligen äh Chef vom Frauen National in Frankreich. Gesagt hatte. Wenn es geht, umso rechtspopulismus, will man den das Original oder will man die Kopie
Also man will grob, so das Original. Und das bedeutet, dass aus meiner Sicht Labour kann,
diese Arten von von Sitzen,
nicht zurückgewinnen, wenn die einfach alles von den konservativen kopieren. Ne, also Label kann nicht nationalistischer.
Sein oder nicht mehr pro Brexit sein als die Konservativen? Das geht einfach nicht. Und wenn man dann schaut,
Wie ist die Situation im Süden? Also jahrzehntelang hat Labour faktisch keine Sitze im Süden Englands gewonnen, aber die haben
dem Londoner Bürgermeister wieder mit einer überragenden Mehrheit, also City Canis Super wie wie noch nie, aber man muss auch sagen, der konservative Kandidat war sehr schwach
Aber auch in
in Kleinstädten rund um London, also zum Beispiel eine sehr reiche Kleinstadt, in der hier, da gewann Labour an Unterstützung in eine ehemalige konservative Hochburg. Also,
Das bedeutet, dass was wir auch in Deutschland gerade beobachten, dass.
Schwele schafften, die traditionell eher CDU in Deutschland gestimmt haben.
Sind jetzt potenzielle Wählerschaften für Grün, vielleicht theoretisch auch für die SPD.
Sehen wir auch jetzt genau das gleiche in Großbritannien,
und dann die Wähler, die dann von von die Linken oder von SPD so der AfD in Deutschland gewechselt sind,
diese Arten von Wähler in Großbritannien gehen dann zu den Konservativen, weil die Konservativen unterstützen, so eine Art dieser Innenblickend,
ängstliche, schmale, nationistische Linie, wie die AfD in Deutschland. Also das ist genau, was wir dann in England so gesehen haben. Also, es gibt dann die große Frage für Labour ist dann.
Was für ein Kurs der Partei.
Überhaupt erfolgreich sein mittelfristig. Also dieses Art einfach die Konservativen zu kopieren das geht nicht,
Also was ist dann den Weg zurück? Und ist alles überhaupt für Star, der noch sehr frisch im armen Parteichef? Der ist jetzt seit dreizehn Monaten erst im Amt.
Er hat was bringt er jetzt als Parteichef eher ist so den Eindruck zur Zeit. Also er hat,
Er hat große Problemen. Und was er auch nicht macht zur Zeit, ist, er bildet keine klare parlamentarische Opposition im im London. Also.
Wenn wir kommen, dann zurück zu diesen Brexit-Frage. Es herrscht gerade in England und auch parteiintern bei den Parteien,
bei den konservativen, sorry. Ein Streit um so die Nachbrexitzukunft des Landes.
Ein Teil der Konservativen wollen möglichst rasch Freihandelsabkommen mit anderen Regionen der Welt abschließen, besonders mit Australien und Neuseeland,
Das bedeutet, keine Zölle für Agrarimpporte aus diese Länder und das ist ein.
Das wäre sehr bitter für die britische Agrarindustrie schon hart betroffen von dem Brexit.
Aber die Bauern sind eine sehr traditionelle Wählergruppe für die konservativen, also bis die Neunziger, über achtzig Prozent der Bauer noch haben für die Konservativen gestimmt,
Aber wenn die Konserve dagegen in Städte wie Harlepol gewinnen können, da hat man einen kompletten Austausch der Wähler, also die.
Die Chromservativen sind die Parteien von den Kleinstädten.
Und die Regionen des Landes und dann anderen Parteien.
An dem Wahlkampf, für die Großstädten und für die eher reicheren ländlichen Raum,
Ja? Ähm also es ist eine komplette umgekehrtes Bild von wie die Wählerschaften von den diversen Parteien aussahen.
Vor zwanzig oder dreißig Jahren.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ein Bild, was wir nicht nur in Großbritannien sehen, das haben wir halt teilweise auch in,
Deutschland unterschiedlichen Ausprägungen,
Und äh ja, das scheint äh ein genereller politischer zu sein. Was hält denn Leber eigentlich davon ab wirklich eine klare Anti-Brexit-Strategie zu
vertreten, weil letzten Endes wissen sie doch, dass das alles Unsinn ist.
Weil die die Partei ist insgesamt sehr nervös. Die haben.
Keine eigene Ideen oder keine politische Pläne. Die haben,
Zukunftsperspektiven. Also die haben ja dann Angst, wenn die kritisieren,
Aspekten des Brexiteals, dass die werden in den Zeitungen kritisiert, dass die gegen den Brexit sind oder für ein,
Erneutes Beitritt sind, also ich erwarte von Labour,
kein pro-europäische Position. Aber äh es wäre aus meiner Sicht möglich für Labour,
Pragmatische Verbesserungen,
der Situation vorzuschlagen. Warum ist ist Labour nicht für einen zwischen die EU und Großbritannien? Also sowas wäre.
Also politisch gesehen nicht problematisch, es wäre pragmatisch gesehen sehr sinnvoll.
Es wäre aus meiner Sicht vollkommen wünschenswert, aber irgendwie lebe es so nervös, dass die aus Partei sind überhaupt nicht in der Lage, sowas vorzuschlagen. Es ist irgendwie, dass die.
Dass dass das praktische Auswirkung.
Eine politische Entscheidung. Fakt ist.
Auswirkungen mehr hat auf die öffentliche, politische Debatte in Großbritannien.
Wieso kann es sein, dass ein nach einer.
Katastrophale Pandemiebekämpfung in so vielen Aspekten, ja? Und den höchsten Todeszahlen europäischen oder weltweiten Vergleich.
Den schwierigsten oder den den größten äh wirtschaftlichen Einbußen ähm äh in unter aller europäischen Länder, dass Boris Johnson.
Immer noch so viel Unterstützung hat und innerhalb der englischen Bevölkerung.
Äh äh die Regierung hat so viele Fehler gemacht. Die Regierung ist so korrupt mittlerweile. Aber das hat keine Auswirkung in die öffentliche Debatte.
Ja, irgendwie hieß es so, Feedback, dass wenn die Regierung was schlechtes tut.
Andere Parteien gewinnen eine Unterstützung.
Diese irgendwie in Großbritannien gebrochen zur Zeit. Ähm und.
Wie kann man sowas lösen? Ähm äh ich habe keine ich habe.
Keine Antworten leider auf diese Frage, aber das ist, was ich gerade beobachte.
Ja, alle sind verzweifelt, ne.
Ja und die es gibt, es es gibt keine Optimismus, nur nichts.
Also äh wer.
Und egal für wen, ja, also diverse Gruppen vor der Industrien oder oder junge Leute oder alte Leute oder keine Ahnung, diverse Regionen oder Universitätsstudenten, weiß ich nicht, ja. Aber.
Irgendwie die Situation ist, dass diese,
Nationalistische Sprüche von von Boris Johnson und das alle anderen sind schuld, also die ganze Problematik, die nur Irland da ist
sind,
die Nordirland oder Brüssel schuld oder die Situation mit den äh Warenverkehr durch doofer. Also ja, also es sind die Börse Europäer, die dann kontrollieren auf der anderen Seite. Es,
Wahnsinn. Es es macht überhaupt keinen Sinn. Aber das kommt noch gut an. In den Medien, ja.
Lass uns mal ein bisschen in die Zukunft schauen, weil ich meine, dass das so ist, haben wir jetzt zur Kenntnis genommen, aber dass das ähm.
Langfristig ja nicht unbedingt jetzt die einzige Überlebensstrategie sein kann, ne? Weil irgendwann
ist es, glaube ich, dann den Leuten auch egal, warum es ihnen schlecht geht. Und ähm die Situation wird sich ja jetzt nicht verbessern. Also ich sehe zumindest
nichts. Also ich habe auch äh ein bisschen rumgeschaut, ob's eigentlich irgendeine Branche gibt, die äh irgendwas zu feiern hat in Großbritannien, aber es scheint ja kein einzigen Sektor zu geben, der in irgendeiner Form sagt, ja super, dass es jetzt Brexit gab, jetzt geht's uns besser.
Kein. Also mir würde jetzt zumindest keiner einfallen. Weißt du was?
Nö. Und und auch die, die so an der Hoffnung haben, also wie, wie die Fische zum Beispiel. Es geht die haben jetzt verstanden, äh es ist ja schlecht, also nee, also,
Es gibt ja keinen Optimismus. Oh und das ist auch während dieser,
Corona-Pandemie, so warte, bis die die Briten wieder reisen dürfen,
und haben dann Schwierigkeiten bei der Einreise in den in oder äh oder dürfen äh nicht mehr als drei Monaten auf einmal in Ferienhäusern in Spanien verbringen und so weiter. Ähm,
Na ja, äh aber irgendwie was ist für die meisten, die Alternative? Ja, also.
Wenn wir blicken kurz zurück, äh nach äh den Unterauswahl zwanzigneunzehn, ja.
Leute haben dann für Labour gestimmt. In der Hoffnung, dass Leber wäre halbwegs.
Eine könnte eine Alternative irgendwie anbieten.
Aber schau mal, was die was Label jetzt tut. Also Labo sagt und der frisch gewählte Bürgermeister von Manchester ähm Manchester, Andy Burnheim. Habe ich gesagt, vor ein paar Tagen.
Aber was für ein Schwachsinn ist das? Also was gibt es so im praisen? Ja, also es gibt es bringt ja nichts, ja gar nichts.
Ähm also das äh das bedeutet ähm.
Es gibt nichts nichts zu umarmen, ja.
Wie äh man man braucht eine.
Ein Weg ohne eine oder eine Perspektive aus diesem Müdigkeit
in diese Pflicht ist Müdigkeit in in Großbritannien. Habe ich sehe den Weg nicht, also ich sehe nur in Schottland halbwegs Optionen
Ein Verein, die sie ihr Land auch in die Probleme ist, irgendeine Perspektive. Schottische Unabhängigkeit ist irgendwie trotz aller Probleme damit, irgendwie es gibt eine gewisse Optimismus dadrin. Aber
Was für Optionen oder oder ähnliches Optimismus gibt es überhaupt in England zur Zeit?
Ja, also diese Leute, Innenstädte wie.
Leben irgendwie von einer Lüge, dass das das Leben wird irgendwie besser werden, weil faktisch ist es nicht besser geworden. Ja, faktisch gesehen.
Also, man hat diese Idee, dass in irgendeine,
Perspektive ist mittelfristig, weil Boris Johnson das mehrmals gesprochen hat, sein sein, ja, so etwas für die Armen Regionen zu tun.
Ja? Aber äh wenn wir demnächst eine Unterauswahl erreichen.
Was hätte er da erreicht? Also.
Äh er führt so diese so äh sehr so.
Ähm so Kulturkampfartiges ähm.
Politik, also Stil nach dem Art von den nordamerikanische Republikaner. Aber irgendwann mal.
Auch dieses meerikanische Wählerschaft war klug genug zu sehen, okay das reicht uns jetzt. Wir wählen dann beiden, aber.
Diese diese,
Änderung der öffentlichen Diskussion in Großbritannien fand zur Zeit nicht statt.
Aber wenn man schaut, was die britische Regierung jetzt vorschlägt, in,
was vorgesehen ist für zum Beispiel, wie Museen gehen mit britische Geschichte um
Das wird dann vorgeschlagen, dass ein positives Blick von den britischen Kolonialgeschichte dargestellt werden muss.
Das ist urban oder oder aus Polen mäßig. Ja, also,
Wir haben es in anderen Ländern der EU nicht verstanden. Weil besonders in Deutschland ist es auch noch in unserer Gedanke, dass
Großbritannien war und ist ein ein demokratisches, ein pragmatisches, ein hartweg funktionsfähiges Land. Also es kann.
Es kann nicht sein, dass dieses Land so schlecht regiert, sagen kann.
Aber ist es ist doch eine Tatsache geworden. Ähm äh und irgendwie.
Irgendwie wie fern, wie weit das geht. Ja ähm.
Oder dieses Freihandelsabkommen, die Diskussion der letzten Tagen, dieses Freihandelsabkommen zwischen Australien und Großbritannien, also.
Was die Australier wollen, das ist ja klar, weil die haben feierndes Abkommen, die seit Jahrzehnten verhandelt und und und abgeschlossen. Die wollen möglichst viel Fleisch.
Agrarprodukte exportieren. Was will Großbritannien in ein Freihandelsabkommen? Großbritannien will den politischen.
Erfolg, dass sie haben ein Freihandelsabkommen abgeschlossen.
Aber sie haben ja nichts davon.
Die kriegen ja nichts davon, weil die wissen nicht, was davon die dann wollen. Wenn man hört, den Handelsministerin sagt, es ist eine Priorität für uns, dass wir ein Freihandelsabkommen mit Australien abschließen. Ja, wer, was ist den Vorteil.
Ja, ist so. Es gibt ja kein faktisches Vorteil. Aber was ist dann Politik in Großbritannien, wenn das bringe keine Vorteile für die
Bewirkung, ja? Also Augenmagel Fati, ja, was getan hatte in der, in der Achtziger, das waren so krass ideologisch geprägtes Politik
aber doch am Ende, es stand hinter dieser Politik.
Sie wollte das Leben für bestimmte Gruppen der britischen Gesellschaft verbessern. Man könnte dann sagen, okay
das ist nicht gelungen in mancher in manchen Fällen, äh in manchen Industriestätten gab's deutlich größere soziale Probleme,
wegen dieses Politik von von damals. Aber,
sie war klar, also wollte nie hatte eine Ahnung, wem will ich praktisch helfen?
Die jetzige Regierung dieser Arten von Fragen nicht. Ja, es ist so eine.
So unglaublich krasse, ideologisch geprägte Regierung in London, es kaum vorzustellen,
Im Vergleich, ja, wir haben den Deutschen aller Angst, von Leute wie Merz oder Maaßen, innerhalb der der CDU. Aber diese Leute sind Pragmatisten im Vergleich,
so so Leute wie wie David Frost oder Boris Johnson.
Also man muss nicht unbedingt einer Meinung sein mit dem, was sie wollen, aber sie wollen zumindest irgendwas, aber man hat wirklich äh bei der britischen Regierung das Gefühl, es geht gar nicht darum, irgendwas zu erreichen. Es geht nur darum, das Gefühl zu vermitteln, dass irgendwas getan werden würde.
Ja genau und und dass man dank Brexit die Freiheit gewonnen hat.
Freihandelsabkommen mit Australien abschließen zu können. Das bedeutet nicht, dass man das machen muss und auf jeden Fall bedeutet das nicht, dass man muss, dass das.
Möglichst raschen schnell machen soll, ja? Überlegt doch mal, was man mit so einer Freihandelsabkommen erreichen will.
Wer wird dann gewinnen und wer wird dann damit verlieren? Weil es werden ja bestimmt Verlierer geben. Und so eine Auswertung von die die Gewinner und Verlierer in so einer,
ähm äh so eine Diskussion sind äh.
So findet nicht statt. In Großbritannien zur Zeit.
Es war eine komplette Enthüllung der des politischen Systems.
Aber es müsste ja eigentlich zu, zu den nächsten Wahlen zwanzig vierundzwanzig müsste sicher die Situation, ist auch zwanzig vierundzwanzig, ne, oder dreiundzwanzig? Äh.
Ja, alle
Dezember vierundzwanzig. Normalerweise finden Wahlen in Mai, in Großbritannien statt, so für wir vermuten, dass die Konservativen werden das dann Mai zwanzig vierundzwanzig organisieren. Es gibt Gerüchte, dass die werden das,
vorzeitig machen, um die jetzige.
Sehr schwache, von der jetzt gesehen schwache Position der Labelpartei zu profitieren.
Ja? Ähm.
Nicht dieses Jahr. Ähm vielleicht nächstes Jahr oder zwanzig dreiundzwanzig. So ein bisschen vorzeitig. Ähm aber das ist auch so unglaublich krass, dass wenn die so was dann.
Erreichen, dass.
Großbritannien könnte dann zwanzig achtundzwanzig erreichen mit mit einer konservative Regierung. Ich so, achtzehn Jahren an der Macht, das ist genauso lang wie die Periode von von Markus und äh und John Major.
Es macht mir ehrlich, sehr, sehr tiefe Sorge.
Okay, ich wohne in Deutschland. Das ist für mich okay. Ich bin froh, dass ich hier lebe. Aber wenn ich blicke nach Großbritannien zurück, also äh.
Und es ist nicht das, ich akzeptiere ja, Brexit, Brexit fand statt, also ich war damals dagegen, klar, okay. Akzeptiert. Aber das bedeutet nicht, dass man man muss.
Politik nach so eine krasse Art und Weise ausführen, dass.
Warum kann man keinen Weg finden, die Leute irgendwie halbwegs zu schützen,
Also, diese Kernaufgaben des britischen Staates gingen verloren in letzter Zeit. Ähm und ich hatte so.
War vielleicht doof so eine Hoffnung zu haben, dass es es könnte vielleicht ein bisschen besser.
Gehen nach dem formellen Austritt. Ja, das ist jetzt gelöst. Vielleicht gibt's dann den Fokus in Großbritannien auf anderen Politikfelder. Nein. Es ist nicht zustande gekommen oder noch nicht.
Ja
Realität ist halt noch nicht komplett angekommen und deshalb kann man sich, glaube ich, auch noch viel äh schönreden und dass es irgendwie besser werden würde, aber ich denke halt mal, in den nächsten zwei Jahren äh wird es sich jetzt einfach so entwickeln und es ist relativ klar,
Handelsabkommen mit Japan und Australien, Neuseeland nicht viel bringen wird also auf jeden Fall nicht diesen Status einer die sie sich da
äh herbeisenieren. Es wird äh mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit auch nicht zu einem Handelsabkommen mit den USA kommen, weil daran hat Joe Biden.
Unwahrscheinlich.
Ja, also das äh grad durch die Nordirlands Situation, der hat dann natürlich als als äh Amerikaner irischer Abstammung auch eine relativ klare Position und äh außerdem versteht er die die Realität,
Das muss man eben ja zu Gute halten.
Ja und ähm von daher denke ich mal, gibt's relativ wenig Spielraum und irgendwann äh denke ich mal äh dürften der, dürfte die Bevölkerung ja auch fragen, äh okay, also äh wo wo ist denn jetzt hier das Brexit-Gedeck
wo ist denn hier äh der Preis, den wir jetzt endlich bekommen für diese ganze Leidensphase und wenn sich das halt nicht einstellt und danach sieht's halt eigentlich aus,
äh und das ist so ein bisschen die Befürchtung, die ich habe. Eigentlich kann,
Es kann ja zwei Sachen bedeuten, ne? Es kann halt sein, dass diese dass sich das dieses Regierungsgedöns dann irgendwann nicht mehr halten kann, weil sie einfach keine
einfach nicht liefert.
Andererseits haben wir auch gesehen, wie äh Regierung heutzutage reagieren, wenn sie eigentlich nicht liefern können. Sie bauen halt immer größere Luftschlösser auf und äh reagieren im Zweifelsfall auf Druck eben mit Gegendruck und äh radikalisieren sich.
Das ist durchaus etwas, was ich so sehen kann in England. Also gerade, wenn man jetzt mal denkt, Schottland spaltet sich ab, dann äh,
unabhängig jetzt mal von Wales, dann dann würde sich noch mehr auf diese englische Identität äh konzentrieren, dann wäre es,
mehr so dieses definierende wir gegen alle anderen und wir sind nur noch von Feinden um umzingelt und
bis er halt schnell in so einem Modus, wo du auch wirklich nur noch mit Feinden agierst und dann äh im Zuge dieser Radikalisierung noch mehr Vollidioten in entscheidende Position bringst und dann einfach auch wirklich zu Konflikten kommen kann,
Meine man wir hatten ja schon diese absurde Situation. Weißt du, da gab's ja diese diese Insel Jersey
von irgendwelchen Fischerbooten blockiert wurde, wo dann irgendwie auch äh schon Militärschiffe losgeschickt wurden, wo man sich auch fragt so, wo geht's noch irgendwie? Äh.
Ja, aber der hat das halt auch für gute Schlagzeilen gesorgt in den britischen Boulevardzeitungen, ja.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Das war in zwei Tagen vor der vor der Wahl. Hat Boris Johnson deutlich geholfen, ja?
Ist wirklich eine Ehre. Ähm ja ähm und glücklicherweise auf der französischen Seite, also es geht, es gab.
Weniger Reaktionen. Ja aber und die Reaktionen in den britischen,
Situation. Da gibt's auch kaum Änderungen, ähm dass
Brüssel ist für alles schuld, ähm es sind die problematischen, die alles blockieren, alle Schwierigkeiten mit den noririschen Protokoll und und und alle Schwierigkeiten an der Grenze
das das ist nicht wegen den wegen den Brexit, sondern wegen die die Ausführung von,
ähm von Bürokraten in Bus ja ähm.
Ja, es macht keinen Sinn, aber das ist Politik, die ich in Großbritannien gerade.
Ja und äh die eigene Regierung ist eigentlich voll mit ungewählten Bürokraten.
Hier genau und ja also der sitzt in dem Haus ja äh der war vorher ähm Botschafter von Großbritannien in Dänemark.
Und dann Cheflobbyist von den schottischen ähm äh schottischen Whiskys äh so den den Handels äh den ähm Industrievertretungssäufe für Schottiges Whisky.
Und dann irgendwie ist er dann Berater von Boris Johnson geworden und jetzt ist der Chefhundeverhandler,
Ja äh ich ich finde das ein bisschen nur ungewöhnlich, dass Großbritannien hatte immer ein Problem mit ungewählter Bürokraten in den in Brüssel. Und jetzt äh der der Chef unter Verhandler ist ein ungewähltes Bürokrat. Ähm.
Naja.
John, ich glaube an der Stelle können wir äh ein Ende machen, auch wenn das äh nach wie vor.
Ich nicht dem optimistischen Ende.
Nee, ist ja auch ziemlich äh ziemlich schwierig, ne.
Aber auf jeden Fall mal ganz gut, mal wieder so einen äh Synchronisation mit den Geschehnissen zu machen. Was gibt's denn so äh in der nächsten Zeit für Ereignisse, auf die man warten kann, wo sich nochmal Dinge entscheiden müssen.
Im Sommer, Juni, Juli gibt's noch diese Spannungen an der an die beiden Grenzen in Not in.
Note in Großbritannien und Großbritannien die EU. Ähm.
Die Frage ist, erreicht Großbritannien irgendwann mal den Punkt.
Den äh entweder den nordirischen Protokoll außer Kraft zu setzen auf die Seite oder den sogenannten,
Artikel sechs sehen zu verwenden um Kontrolle an von Waren einzuführen.
Zur Zeit lehnte auch Frost diese Optionen ab, aber wenn die Debatte
immer heftiger wird, wie es so die die Richtung in den letzten paar Monaten, da habe ich dann Angst, dass man erreicht, ein Punkt, wo wo Großbritannien alleine trifft eine sehr radikale.
Und aus meiner Sicht, die Ideologische ähm Entscheidung.
Zweite Hälfte von dieses Jahr in Großbritannien ist theoretisch ruhig. Es gibt keine Wahlen.
Britische Unterhaus, in der sie diese so nach Pandemie Zeit.
Könnte dann vielleicht so Arbeitsthemen.
Reguläre Themen zurückkehren. Also das ist zumindest die Hoffnung. Also es es gibt.
Es gibt nicht nicht so wichtige Meilensteine in den nächsten sechs bis neun Monate.
Außer wenn die Situation in Nordirland viel schlechter wird. Ähm also ich hoffe ehrlich gesagt eben, dass wir keinen Brexit-Podcast mehr machen müssen für sechs Monate. Ähm aber wir sehen halt mal, oh das so wirklich.
Alles klar. Gut, dann sage ich äh vielen Dank, John, für die Ausführung.
Ja und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei äh UKW. Ähm als nächstes gibt's dann mal wieder ein bisschen Corona, hatten wir ja schon lange nicht mehr. Und äh bis dahin sage ich tschüss und bis bald.